also ich würde schon sagen dass es das
ist eine art große familie ist nein das
ist nicht dein ernst wer könnte denn hin
zukunft mal wieder ein paar werden
mit daniel gefällt mir total gut an die
oft sogar mit der auch nicht warum ich
sehe meine klappe
[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen stadland
bild ausgabe 15 und das ist unsere
zweite extra staffel gzsz nach dem
großen erfolg
schon im letzten jahr haben wir uns
gesagt da packen was drauf und ich finde
wir haben eine ganz ganz tolle runde
hier und ich begrüße zunächst eine dame
die eigentlich für mich so gzsz ausmacht
und sie ist ja noch weit mehr süße
schauspielerin
sie spielt am theater und ich freue mich
ganz besonders auf katrin flemming so
heißt der serie auch ulrike fragen schön
dass du dabei wird und dann haben wir
noch eine andere dame dabei die nicht
ganz so lange wie ulrike dabei war aber
auch immerhin knapp vier jahre bei gzsz
nicht gespielt hat sowie sängerin die
tanja seefeld in der serie herzlich
willkommen senta sofia delliponti und
abgehört wenn ich dich center nene bist
du damit einverstanden so und da muss
ich sagen wenn man als man sowas
moderiert um sich vorbereitet müsste man
ja eigentlich sagen auf den den ich
jetzt vorstelle muss eigentlich
jedermann in meinem alter so ein
bisschen neidisch eifersüchtig sein er
wurde von den schönsten frauen
angehimmelt
auch er hat ja noch viel viel mehr zu
bieten als nur ein frauenschwarm zu sein
aber das ist ja auch nicht das
schlechteste attribut ich begrüße leon
moreno alias daniel fehlow hallo grüß
dich
daniel wie ist es für dich wenn man wenn
man sowas hört und man hat auch immer
den eindruck wenn ich eben gerade
gesehen habe wie ihr zusammen geschaltet
wurden wurden und wie auch die
ehemaligen kollegen darüber nicht
gesprochen haben als beschützer gzsz
sonderfolge hatten
ist es wirklich so dass ihr so eine art
große familie
damals war bzw gibt es heute noch
kontakt
also ich würde schon sagen dass es dass
es eine art große familie ist wir
arbeiten ja nun in dem sinne fast
täglich zusammen also man sieht sich
fast täglich und dann zwangsläufig
entstehen da irgendwie herzliche
kontakte und man kennt sich lange also
zum beispiel uli und ich wir kennen uns
ja nun wirklich auch dadurch schon sehr
lange und haben auch ein sehr
liebevolles verhältnis zueinander
und ja dann gehen natürlich immer mal
ein paar leute und dann kommen wieder
leute und dann muss ich das alles immer
irgendwie weiter entwickeln aber im
großen und ganzen ist es für mich dieses
family feeling schon irgendwie immer
noch dabei muss ich sagen ja und ihr
wart ja auch mal ab also das ist
tatsächlich so eine geschichte jetzt wie
wie mit dir sender sieht sich vielleicht
nicht so oft da hat nicht so viel
kontakt und trotzdem wenn man sich dann
sieht das ist frei ganz vielen sehr
herzliches sehr enges verhältnis wenn
man verbringt ja schon sehr viel zeit
bei so einer täglichen serie miteinander
am set und dass das verbindet einfach ja
und ulrike und daniel waren ja auch mal
ein paar in der serie ulrike wenn der
jetzt noch so siehst deinen ehemaligen
serienpartner irgendwie fühlt sich das
gerade an
natürlich hat die geschichte damals
sicherlich auch dazu beigetragen dass
wir uns immer noch sehr herzlich
verbunden sind und wirklich freunde
geworden sind
so kathrin und leon das war für kt in
der serie die erste richtig große
liebesgeschichte muss man sagen und die
dinge auch eine ganze zeit lang und sehr
dramatisch mit kind und entführung union
also wahnsinn was wir da alles erlebt
haben und nach wie vor also immer wenn
es darum geht wer könnte denn in zukunft
mal wieder ein paar werden werde ich
also das wäre nie verkehrt aber
natürlich immer viele neue möglichkeiten
hast du hier aus blau das wohl wirklich
ich kann mich sogar daran erinnern dass
das früher mal in der zeitung spekuliert
wurde ob ihr nicht sogar privat
irgendwie ein paar sein könnten obwohl
ja zu der zeit auch schon verheiratet
wäre legen denn zumindest oder daniel n
typ gewesen wo du gesagt hat dass auch
der gefällt mir im privaten bereich
da hier gefällt mir total gut
verantworten
also absolut und die also umso besser
wenn dann spekuliert wird ob das auch so
mal irgendwie sich fortsetzt dann ist es
klar würde ich an einem halben jahr sein
job gemacht und ich freue mich sehr mit
euch zu spielen ihr kennt die regeln
sind ganz normal wie bei stadt land
fluss für eine richtige antwort gibt es
zehn punkte
wenn jemand anderer oder alle drei
dieselbe antwort haben dann gibt es nur
fünf punkte und seid ihr der alleinige
in einer kategorie
dann gibt es einen zwanziger und es gibt
auch heute wieder einen joker den
könnten egal wann ihr wollt nach jeder
spielrunde setzen aber insgesamt nur
einmal und da möchte ich den titelsong
von gzsz von euch hören gesungen
das kann so weit wie nur irgend etwas
aber das ist und damit könnt ihr einen
nuller einen fünf- oder einen zehner
aufwerten oder ersetzen und dann würde
ich euch jetzt bitten die fünf
kategorien zu notieren
da haben wir zunächst als kategorie
einen gzsz totti also einen heißen typen
aus der serie
sodann habe ich als zweite kategorie
einen casting trick also wie kann man
ein erfolgreiches casting absolvieren
und was hat man da vielleicht schon mal
gehört oder selber angewendet um dort
erfolgreich zu sein dann als trist einen
film bösewicht also das kann ein jo
gerner sein das kann aber auch jemand
sein aus film und fernsehen aus den
großen hollywood verfilmungen
irgendjemanden bösen dann haben wir als
vierte kategorie eines marotte also was
eine marotte die hier am set selber habt
oder bei kollegen schon mal beobachtet
hat eine set man hatte ja zb dass der
eine vielleicht irgendwie immer bevor er
auftritt auf die toilette läuft oder
sowas oder dass er immer einen kaffee
trinkt das wäre zum beispiel solche
möglichkeiten so viel müsste wüsste was
dabei sein und als letztes jeweils eine
wild schlagzeile die ist aber dann
fiktiv aber ihr könnt euch irgendetwas
einfallen lassen diesen buchstaben und
in der ersten runde hätte ich gerne
fiktive schlagzeilen über eure rolle bei
gzsz habt ihr das so weit alles
akustisch auch verstanden
das ist schön und dann sage ich noch an
unsere zuschauer dass ihr natürlich auch
wieder mitspielen können es geht einfach
auf den link dann den zettel ausdrucken
für die heutige ausgabe und schauen ob
ihr bester wert also unsere gzsz romys
zugleich gibt es dann zwei minuten zeit
hier haben wir nachher ein signal eine
filmklappe da gebe ich euch dann ab und
ich würde jetzt anfangen zu zählen das
alphabet mit a und ulrike würde die
stadt witten irgendwann stopp zu sagen
und ich gebe euch dann den buchstaben
vor soweit alles klar
jetzt als der toll und wer als erstes
fertig ist kann stopp rufen und
dann fallen die stifter direkt runter
also wir starten mit
das ist ein haar wie camburg und wir
starten in drei zwei eins und los
also ich sags stopp das ist nicht dein
ernst allen fünf kategorien
ach so schön schön ich habe nur die
erste gebracht weil da so machen dass
die jungs um die mädels zu holen
[Musik]
sehr interessant beobachten will rhi
gaben lächeln auf den lippen sind da
ganz konzentriert
[Musik]
ja
doch
center mit trockenübungen das ist
richtig es geht richtig
[Musik]
im heißen typen lasse ich natürlich
sowohl den richtigen namen als auch in
serien namen gelten zb ein glück
seit ich fünf vier drei zwei eins und
stoppt recht nicht einfach
dann ist nicht einfach das nimmt ja wir
hatten hier schon kategorien da haben
die vorhergesagte ich dachte wir spielen
stadt land fluss und wer weiß denn dass
sie halten würde passen dass er immer an
und es ist wirklich nicht ganz einfach
ulrike ich würde dich bitten zunächst
immer seine antwort vorzulesen dann sage
ich mir das mit den beiden anderen also
wer ist dein heißer typ oder auch
weiblich eine heiße typen oder ein
heißes mädel ein heißes gehört also am
set von gzsz gibt es einen heißen typen
und das ist den firmen das ist der hund
[Gelächter]
wirklich und ich habs gerade am lachen
wir meinen namen gesehen das ist so
originell jedem auf jeden fall zehn
dafür center wie sieht die aus ich habe
da gar nichts du hast oder gar nichts
eingefallen wirklich nicht eruiert echt
nachgedacht dachte h
da musst du hast ja vielleicht gleich
den joker noch in der hinterhand und ich
habe die schlimme ja eben schon gehört
das könnte ja hassen daniel wie sie zwar
aus ich habe mich für einen für einen
ehemaligen kollegen entschieden der
jetzt nicht mehr dabei ist aber der
aufmerksame werde dabei war und der dann
auch ein sehr guter freund von mir im
nachhinein geworden ist und das ist
hendrik borgmann und das genau gefragt
die ladies ist ein ros' die auf jeden
fall her also und zähler natürlich für
daniel dank jetzt den job ja die gab
sich die aktionäre gehen
ich sehe dein herz sehr gute zeiten
schlechte zeiten ein leben was neu und
damit stärke das hier 14 tage gerade mit
20 punkten die beiden anderen haben zehn
aber haben natürlich ihren sohn auch
noch den see natürlich ziehen können
willich den ziehen will nicht ohne geld
casting trick vor dem casting einen
handstand machen weil dann bist du hast
energie du hast also du bist zentriert
weil wir den handstand machen kannst
dann bist du zentriert und du hast noch
mal die perspektive gewechselt
bist ganz im körper und dann kannst du
musst das findet gibt auf jeden fall
szene
was sagst du ich hab händeschütteln
man sich einfach locker tja gemeinsam
mit dem ganzen körper und dass man
einfach sich damit verbindet man ganz
oft sind die handy also steigt oder auf
jeden fall positiv und was sein was sagt
mit da ist der eiszeit ein heißer tee
das passt ja noch ein paar
da wird dir warm ums herz das ist schon
nochmal schön gewärmt kann es noch mal
zur ruhe kommen kann es nochmal
achtsamen werden und wie sie gerade
gesagt hat dann bist du auch ganz bei
dir und kannst authentisch deine nummer
einfach durchlaufen sie haben natürlich
nur dumm wenn es irgendwie ein bisschen
warm ist und dann anfängt zu schwitzen
wenn dann auch noch das licht dazu kommt
konsequent sein konto oder viel werden
ulrike was hast du von film bösewicht
da habe ich auch ewig überlegt mir ist
erst überhaupt niemand eingefallen und
dann kam ich auf den haag
ja natürlich der grüne holz aus dem
bericht ist doch cool
[Gelächter]
kennt ihr die nicht das ist so ein
bisserl ne richtige schauspieler der
heißt auf jeden fall ferch und der heißt
heino ferch aber ist das ist das immer
der bösewicht das ist jetzt nicht da
kann wirklich und eigentlich fragen soll
natürlich würde ich sagen eigentlich
fragen wir natürlich nach einer
filmfigur aber auf der anderen seite
finde ich ja fast schon wieder kreativ
dass er das du sogar weiß dass der so
oft den bösewicht spielt und deshalb ein
salomonisches urteil du bekommst fünf
punkte dafür fielen
das ist
sehr guter deutscher schauspieler und
das wird mit fünf bewertet
daniel wir sind bei dir aus ich fand es
echt schwer
ich habe wirklich lange überlegt bis mir
dann eingefallen ist
es gibt einen film da gibt es auch ein
bösewicht und zwar der weiße hai und
wenn der nicht böse ist von wem alle
angst haben super sodann eine sex
marotte ulrike also ich habe immer in
meiner tasche eine handcreme damit ich
mir immer die händler 1 klink an wie man
hier sieht
okay das ist hier das heute sehen toll
ich habe jetzt sowieso natürlich wenn
wir uns dauernd die hände desinfizieren
die sind total trocken aber auch sonst
habe ich immer eine hand gehen dabei
damit ich dann schöne hände habe wenn
ich drehe zehn punkte center super ich
habe heizkissen heizkissen aus der hand
in den taschen in der in den in den dem
syndrom aus motten und dann sind die 80
du musst es noch abnehmen sieht es beim
kostüm ihre heizkissen und da muss man
die noch abgehen soll auch das gibt eine
szene
ich habe ich weiß nicht glaube ich
sollte nicht sagen von welchem kollegen
kenne aber halswirbel knacken so dieses
knapp und das kannst du sagen dass jede
stimme ist haben sie die kollegen das
ganze noch sicher nennen das ist ja
nichts böses
ja ich selber ich frage sie einen freund
ok auch das ist
10 also ich merke schon alle immer auf
entspannung aus bevor es dann ernst wird
und dann fehlt uns noch die bild
schlagzeile über eure eigene rolle bei
gzsz hat katrin flemming eine schwester
sehr gut dann center heißt tanja zieht
blank
wäre das was für dich
ich habe da nicht so ein exhibitionist
ischen wunsch nicht zu akzeptierende
lose bei mir fällt gerade noch ein
ulrike du warst ja auch mal dem playboy
glaube vor
vor 67 jahren wie was für eine erfahrung
war das für dich ja also bei mir war das
irgendwie ganz lustig weil er weiß auch
schon 45 glaube ich und dann kam die
anfrage an meine agentur und die haben
dann gesagt ja da kam so eine anfrage
aber das ist ja nichts und dann dachte
ich warum eigentlich nicht und habe mich
da mal ein bisschen mehr damit befasst
und habe dann gemerkt erstens das war ja
erstklassig fotografen fotografinnen
arbeiten und mit einem riesenaufwand
dieses votings gemacht werden und die
waren auch total offen wie das dann im
einzelnen ist also welche welche welchen
stil oder irgend welche richtung das
gehen kann und dann dachte ich auch dass
ich doch mal aus und dann waren wir drei
tage lang in einem französischen schloss
und es war richtig toll toller fotograf
wilfried wohl ganz ganz toll und hat mir
echt spaß gemacht und sind auch für mich
tolle fotos rausgekommen mit denen ich
mich sehr wohl fühle und ich bereue es
nichts das ist gemacht
eine schlagzeile ist hau den lukas leon
box wieder auf dem weg nach der ersten
runde führt sender mit 55 punkten vor
und schafft vor daniel mit jeweils 50
die beiden haben aber natürlich noch die
option eines jokers wir kommen zu runde
zwei und bei der fiktiven schlagzeile
hätte ich dann gerne eine über euch
selbst also über euch als private person
nicht als gzsz was könnte über euch in
der bild zeitung stehen ich würde sagen
ich starte mit dem alphabet und würde
center bitten dann ein stopp zu sagen
das ist ein es siegfried und es geht los
bei 321 klappe fällt
[Musik]
nach der ersten runde so häufig
endlose richtige teams berichten müssen
bösewicht der oder fehlen
schreckgespenster alters ist
wir haben noch zehn sekunden 321 und
stock und man sieht ihr seid
hochkonzentriert ich kann mir vorstellen
so sieht das dann ungefähr aus
wahrscheinlich wenn ihre texte lernen
was wir machen
britz einem gzsz hobby und ich würde sie
bitten immer zu beginnen mit dem
buchstaben s susan sideropoulos oder
center sofia wer die punkte wäre auch
mit recht wie sie gedauert
[Gelächter]
ich hab's eigennamen gespielt von deinen
tina fey und der daniel hier sogleich
als sofort susan in den kopf geschossen
aber ich habe doch du hast doch eben
center gesagt dann habt ihr meine damen
hingestellt aber ich dachte es geht ja
wohl mehr weil du es gerade gesagt ist
jan es geht ihr kriegt alle 13 punkte
der männer - ganz genau so
dann ein casting trick mit s
einfach die stimme zu aktivieren in
seinen körper zu einem spirituellen ja
sehr kreativ schwäbisch reden also
dialekt indien die szenen einfach im
heimatdialekt machen ja dann klickt man
dann ganz anderen zugang und hatte die
chance verschiedene dialekte sprechen
oder nur dann heimatdialekt also schrieb
ich kann ihr ganz gut schmelzer das
macht daniel casting trick hast du in
dem fall habe ich das schütteln genommen
wird es schütteln einfach nicht locker
machen
wir haben jetzt eine schwierige phase in
corona zeiten also es kommt ja gar nicht
zu castings groß oder ganz ganz selten
ist alles viel viel schwieriger geworden
center dass sie eine erfolgreiche sänger
wenn auch dieses in deiner branche und
für die selbst persönlich schon sehr
schwierig also dadurch dass die ganzen
live konzerte und all diese sachen die
stadt findet man eigentlich sein letztes
jahr april im locker und ist
diesbezüglich aber es gibt jetzt einen
lichtblick am 21.8 auf rügen das erste
open air konzert und da wollen wir das
irgendwie miteinander einfließen lassen
euch ich hoffe so sehr dass das
stattfindet es wäre dann das erste
konzert nach eineinhalb jahren
ich sage auch als die zusage kam war ich
nur so kann ich das überhaupt noch
wir werden auf jeden fall die daumen
drücken also einem halben jahr dann auf
rügen toi toi toi
ulrike du hast ja am theater viel
stunden gespielt sehr erfolgreich
gespielt ich glaube dein ehemann der
komponiert auch theater musik das ist ja
eine branche die unfassbar hart
getroffen ist
wie empfindest du das ganze im moment ja
es ist wirklich sehr bitter das
mitzuerleben also genau ich habe ja mit
bühne angefangen bin es später dann zu
filmen fernsehen gekommen und habe da
natürlich sehr viele kolleginnen
kollegen freunde
mein mann manchen bringen schreibt
musicals da sind eben also ist er alles
dicht es ist alles abgesagt und man weiß
ja noch gar nicht man hat keine
perspektive
also müsste ok erster achter geht wieder
los aber es ist eben alles noch
vollkommen im nebel lösung ich selber
habe den ersten oktober eine
theatertournee premiere geplant dieses
jahr ein gemeiner trick wollen wir da
eigentlich starten und dann auf tournee
gehen
ob das stattfinden wird keine ahnung ich
hoffe es ganz ganz schwieriges thema und
viele ringen da tatsächlich nach fast
einem jahr jetzt auch so ein bisschen um
die existenz daumen drücken sich
möglichst viele oder alle durchhalten
können jetzt muss ich mal ganz kurz ein
fragen ich habe gelesen und dann musste
ich wirklich minseln
das ist zum beispiel auch eine kuss
quarantäne gibt also dass man in
quarantäne muss focus oder liebesszenen
freakig doch was tatsächlich ein kuss
quarantäne wie war das
ich hab schon zwei mal gemacht und ich
werde es auch wieder tun
zwei wochen sein müssen
nein also natürlich kommt auch die
geschichten an und gerade wenn es eine
liebesgeschichte ist wie jetzt bei uns
bei katrin und tobias mit nähe und
distanz wo immer wieder dann sind sie
wieder zusammen dann wieder nicht dann
muss man auch mal die nähe sehen damit
man emotional als zuschauer in dann auch
weiter mitgeht und und das wirklich
glaubwürdig ist ja wir haben dann
innerhalb von fünf tagen zwei pcr tests
gemacht haben diese trendlinie gemacht
und dann durften wir einen und beim
zweiten messer
zwei tage gemacht mit hotelübernachtung
beleben das dass wir zwei volle drei
tage hatten und das hat super
funktioniert was war dein bestes
ergebnis bei gzsz was waren ein großer
reinfall
eine anekdote an die ich mich noch
erinnern das ist lange her da war
nämlich alexander l der luft als katja
das war damals leons leons große liebe
und da hatten wir einmal eine kussszene
und leider irgendwie aus welchem grund
auch immer
ich hatte meinen körper nicht unter
kontrolle
es war nach dieser szene mittagspause
das heißt also als die szene vorbei war
hieß es okay danke fertig so alle raus
aus der studie nicht nur deinem bett und
dachte ich kann also ist jetzt im
nachhinein wahrscheinlich noch ein
kompliment an haben alex von damals aber
da konnte ich dann eben nicht mehr
unterscheiden und da hat sich halt
körperliche im schnitt fast getan und
ich musste mich auf ein paar richtig
bleibt noch ein bisschen
das klang so schön bleibt kurz liegen
und angelpunkt hast du dir mal gestanden
irgendwann wenn sie es dann nicht jetzt
erfährt
ich habe erfahren dass sie ganz in
meiner nähe gezogen ist und schon kann
man jetzt durch zufall getroffen
ich werde sie erzählen was sie schon
mitglied und von center würde ich gerne
noch wissen ließen das eigentlich wenn
man schauspieler ist und auch
liebesgeschichten verfilmt ist der
eigene partner da manchmal auch
eifersüchtig
nein gar nicht das ist ganz klar ist
dass man einfach das ist ja so technisch
also ich weiß in den zweieinhalb jahren
ruhig da gedreht habe dann ist
wahrscheinlich 1820 kann er war ja mal
so ein rebellisches mädchen was gerne
drauf los ist und acht verschiedene
komparsen in kürzester zeit habe
und es ist ja so technisch gar nicht und
dass das wusste mein partner auch und da
waren wir auch ganz transparent in der
kommunikation
wir müssen wir weiterspielen ich war so
begeistert von dem was sie erleben
sollen gar nicht gezählt
wir brauchen einen film bösewichts
center superman natürlich super wenn es
gibt auch diesen film batman und
superman oder da ist ist einfach mal
superman ist eigentlich glaube ich fasse
positiv besetzt werden glaube ich glaube
dass ich glaube da muss ich jetzt klar
okay das gibt noch mal fünf euro wie sie
zwar die aus ich habe den sandmann also
ich glaube der heißt wirklich so bei den
incredibles diesen sand dieses level
lesen und der ist auch richtig böse ja
ich werde dann irgendwann gut
daniel mir spontan der name eines
schauspieler ist einvernehmlich cargo
absolut und fertigen sky sky die morgen
da geb ich dir vollkommen recht gilt ja
eigentlich als der deutsche film
bösewicht also wenn er irgendwo
auftaucht dann weißt du direkt der hat
irgendwie dreck am stecken also im film
sehen dass ich auf jeden fall gelten was
haben wir mit set marotte liebe centern
singen einstellen
singen einstellen ja besorgnis was denn
los geht ja natürlich klar
das wäre nicht gut wenn man den wir
wollen ein traum wird und warum singen
ulrike leider auch singen
aber du hast ja singen und singen
einstellen das ist natürlich
ja da sind wir natürlich dann schon auch
ganz genau das gibt 2 10 und daniel ich
bin ich bin auch da beim schütteln
auch im schöne form von also casting
situationen und die situation ist ja
irgendwie auch vergleichbar
dass leute ihn wie so ein bild machen
es gibt ja natürlich und vor allen
dingen auch wie du sagst wenn es kalt
ist ist ja fast manchmal auch das
eingefroren da muss man nochmal ein
versprechungen machen und genau so ist
damit die gliedmaßen zehn punkte auch da
ich über mitessern ganz genau und eine
bild schlagzeile über euch selbst center
in sonnige grüße oder center grüßt euch
so meldet sonne sonnenschein grüße das
wäre sogar fast noch etliche regionen
das foto zeigt ulrike frank bei gzsz
nein bitte nicht dass meine überlegung
war dass man immer nein überhaupt nicht
aber das wird immer wieder geschrieben
wenn man meinen urlaub wie sich so eine
schlagzeile denke ich hey warum das denn
jetzt und da war ich dann irgendwie zwei
wochen im urlaub oder theater gespielt
oder so also ich freu mich ja dass die
angst scheinbar groß ist bei vielen von
uns ob wir dabei bleiben ja aber ich
bleibe auf ihn ein
das ist die beste nachricht was ist mit
léon also mit daniel ja genau
mit daniel des serien star möchte wieder
in den urlaub.de urlaub bei uns so gibt
es noch jemanden der singen möchte von
euch beiden
die sogar oder macht er mir noch die
letzte runde gehen wir nach der letzten
runde und natürlich genau aber weil es
ist jetzt wahnsinnig spannend wir haben
nämlich jetzt alle frei bei einigen
punkten also das ist wahnsinnig eng das
hatten wir noch nie nach runde zwei
und wie gesagt ulrike und daniel können
noch singen
ich würde sagen habe ich jetzt mir noch
aus ich zähle noch mal ich bin dann
daneben stopp zu sagen für unsere dritte
und letzte runde
und wir starten nichts doch lieber
thomas daniel das ist stark wir machen
baby berlin
da wo die serie spielt und so starten
drei zwei eins und los
ich musste richtig ab
komm jetzt reiß dich zusammen denkt bei
den hobby ist vielleicht auch mal leute
die aktuell noch dabei sind
der avisierte namen immer nicht so wir
haben noch zehn sekunden 321 und stoppt
so letzte rose starten immer mit daniel
was hast du hast und gzsz nicht
korrigiert ich habe tatsächlich bommeln
genommen also team gespielt und merlin
leonhardts unvergessen unvergessen ist
ihr hat es hätte ich auch genau wie ich
hatte gar nichts ich habe eben zum
beispiel gemeint weil ich auch gesagt
habe es können sich auch der richtige
name sein wolfgang bahro zum beispiel
yoga wer auf einer gewesen mit beta
roboter an die nachnamen denke ich ja ja
ist klar also ein casting trick bitte
von dir daniel jedoch als casting trick
hab ich auch wieder etwas zur
auflockerung und zwar dieses sogenannte
da ist bei dieser lippen redaktion ja
also ich wusste nicht wie es nennen
sollte also das zählt auf jeden fall gut
ich habe bauchfell lockern also dass sie
ja oft verkrampft man so einen braucht
und wie sieht es bei dir aus seinen
übungen bauch übungen um einfach seinen
körper zu aktivieren
dabei geht es etwas anzutun rieger am
start habe ich so den alltag
war ja genau wisst ihr was ich mir die
ganze selbst vorstelle wenn das jetzt
jemand sich anschaut und sich diese
ganzen casting tipps zu herzen nimmt
der ist nicht gekommen der hand zusammen
rein irgendwie unser nach wird die ganze
zeit gelockert und geschüttelt was haben
wir viel gewicht mit b daniel die
bösewichte haben es mir sowieso heute
schwer gemacht aber da da steht nun auf
meinem zettel wie sieht die aus und
räkelt
der film bösewicht schlechthin finde ich
bloß ja und ernst bach hob lohfeld der
dauer bösewicht und gegenspieler von
james bond und da habe ich mir da nicht
eigentlich auch so ein bisschen darauf
gehofft weil wir jungs gucken doch
eigentlich immer alle booms ist das
system integration sei hier ganz genau
ernsthaft lohfeld genau center wiese bei
dem film bösewicht klebe da auch nicht
ich hatte auch vor auf der überlegung
aber okay hinter diesen tag hat sie mir
gesagt hat so benjamin münchen der ist
aber auch nicht immer so lieb also das
war so ein schöner augenaufschlag
dafür gebe ich in 35 sportarten muss ich
dann natürlich die zellen also ich
trinke ich wahrscheinlich riesenärger
hier aber ich finds ich finde es sehr
lustig eine sap marotte ja ich habe mir
jetzt hier in dieses spiel an gewöhnt
dass man diese casting tricks und
marotten eigentlich immer gleichsetzen
kann das gehen
sollte ich mal machen wir jetzt mal wie
locker gesagt war bin ich locker ja
unglaublich ist meine gefühle das wort
wird auch gleich deutlich ausgesprochen
rasant marotte ich hab betteln noch mal
den text zu bekommen
[Gelächter]
ulrike bei dir brötchen essen also es
gibt so die essen so ganz kurz nach
einreichen durch mahlung brötchen ja
genau
am besten ein mettbrötchen mit zwiebeln
vor der kurs zu ändern ja ja ja und dann
haben wir noch die schlagzeile daniel ja
bald auch privat ein paar
paul riegel und jahr
sehr schön center bitte hört euch
[Gelächter]
abzudecken
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
und wie sieht die aus ich habe breite
und kathrin fliegen die fetzen
ja natürlich auch das gibt in szene so
bevor ich dann gleich mit der auswertung
komme und zu meiner schluss fragerunde
wer möchte zuerst singen noch mal
zusammen das geht natürlich auch wenn
ihr zusammen hier nicht das hat sich
super angehört ich würde sagen ja den
joker gezogen und politiker nicht und
sagen das sieht sehr gut aus da nicht
ich habe gehört du bist so ein hobby
oder sehr begabter heimwerker und hast
dir viele möbel auch zu hause selbst
gemacht kannst du kannst du dich mal
kleinen einblick geben
ich muss mal mit ja war ja klar kann ich
gern kann ich gerne machen
jetzt richtet man die kamera um also da
sieht man zum beispiel unseren unsere
fernseh bank die ist auch von mir ja
also alles wieder raus
also eigentlich eigentlich fast
ausschließlich mit holz
hier haben wir das ist mein erster tisch
gewesen die nicht gemacht hat das waren
alte scheunen tür
die ich das verarbeitet habe die stühle
für die kids und auch verlieren ja ja
habe ich auch gebaut und meint mein
persönliches meisterstück das kann ich
euch jetzt noch mal eben schnell hier in
der küche zeigen
das ist unser küchentisch toll das ist
ja das ist ein 100 jahre alter vielen
fußboden aus einem aus einem alten
bahnhofsgebäude aus dem berliner umland
und den habe ich ist ein bekannter von
mir der hat mir den überlassen und da
habe ich unseren tisch ausgebaut die
lampe ist von mir ja alles von mir also
ich habe man könnte das kommt bei frauen
gut an wenn männer auch selbst was tun
könnt also ich würde sagen das
gesamtpaket weil von daniel gut ab
du hast eben gerade gesagt dass du in
einem halben jahr auf rügen endlich
wieder singen im möchtest du hast ja ein
bisschen was von dem projekt erzählt so
ein bisschen von dem grünen projekt das
scheint ihr das hast du eben so ein
bisschen immer mal wieder durchblicken
lassen scheint mir sehr wichtig zu sein
mich hier immer ausschreiben gesehen und
hab mich letztes jahr ab so ganz fair
reflektiert und beschäftige mich sowieso
mein privatleben sehr viel mit
nachhaltigkeit und hab gesehen dass ist
das greenteam network
zum start wird das organisiert dass man
seine tourneen und konzerte grüner zu
gestalten dass man da subventionen
bekommt unterstützung das macht und da
habe ich mich beworben habe ich das
bekommen und das ist halt jetzt auch so
schwierig weil wir sind seit einem
halben jahr in der theorie und wir
können gar nicht praktisch umsetzen
meine tournee im januar ist auch
abgesagt worden aber wenn man dann aber
wenn man deine augen sieht und die
begeisterung mit ihr darüber spricht ich
glaube dann merkt man auch dass die das
ein absolutes anliegen ist und ja das
finde ich ganz toll dass du das auch so
vertritt und zum abschluss würde ich
gerne noch ulrike fragen irgendwie bist
du ja schon die court dann von gzsz und
das ist ja nur positiv gemeint welche
erinnerungen hast du an deinen am ersten
drehtag bei gzsz und ich habe auch mehr
von unseren redaktionen sagen lassen
ich glaube du hast sogar noch dein
erstes outfit das hast du sogar noch
habe ich noch und ich habe es vorhin
gesucht wie bekloppt und ich hab es
nicht gefunden
es tut mir leid also es war ein kleid
und schnarcht das immer noch aufbewahrt
aber dann sagt man die auch sony seine
erinnerungen an die anfänge ich auch
sehr gut also meine allererste szene die
ich tatsächlich gedreht habe war sofort
die liebesszenen mit wolfgang bahro so
gerne hat an silvester einigen ein
online stand mit katrin flemming und das
war tatsächlich die erste szene mit sich
mit mittleren beigetreten und
besorgungen ab mittag im plus
aber deshalb gleich so sofort
funktioniert und hat so viel spaß
gemacht war aber auf der suche nach
diesem kleid bin ich auf alte gzsz
kalender gestoßen und das war total
lustig also die verschiedenen und da ist
noch so ein ganz alter
er ist auch total klasse naja fast aus
der gründerzeit ja also
hier wolfgang berney wo bist du hier
irgendwo mit langhaar
ja ja und natürlich auch hier frank
thomas mende regeln dieser ricken so die
die gramm früher aber toll wenn man
aussieht wie begeistert daniel dann auch
noch ist die ganzen alten kollegen zu
sehen
und apropos begeistert ich muss ich
sagen ich bin total begeistert von
dieser runde ich könnte auch fünf bis
acht spielrunden mit euch dran hängen
das hat riesenspaß gemacht
ich komme jetzt zur siegerehrung dritter
platz für center herzlichen glückwunsch
silber geht an meinen männlichen partner
hier in dieser runde mit 155 punkten
nach dem fehler herzlichen glückwunsch
so und jetzt ich kann euch nur sagen mit
den 155 punkten springt daniel in der
ewigen bestenliste direkt mal auf rang
drei punktgleich mit detlef d soost der
man letzte woche da mit englisch und mit
sarah kulka und von einer frau wird
diese liste ab heute komplett
pulverisiert jede kategorie
einmal alleine plus den jogger sind 170
punkte das ist gold und der erste platz
in der bestenliste
ich sage herzlichen glückwunsch und
verneige mich tief ulrike fahren
ich möchte mich herzlich bedanken ich
hoffe ihr habt ein bisschen freude dabei
absolut wer gerne und ich sage bleibt
gesund und bleibt negativ bis nächste
woche
[Musik]